he's written a very good song and just
at the beginning of the tour he played
it to me and I said we should open the
show with it am I gonna sing it now cuz
it's our joint experience
yes about being on the road and what we
learn unless you need any setup beyond
that or you know so just to say that
it's one from the heart this is one from
the heart up okay here's a little song
it won't take very long
it's about the world today and it's
something we have to say selfies all
those kids who take selfies they just
get on my tits when you're grinning like
a lunatic for people you don't know
it takes them half an ad again the
bloody cameras go and another 14 other
bloody people show selfies are a waste
of bloody time
[Music]
so take tell Shelby Shelby bricks next
time a house
to take their bloody Shelby sticks and
shove them up there ah okay very very
much this is
[Applause]
[Music]
this is going to be can relate to you
know everybody no one wants an autograph
anywhere they all want to sell right and
what's fascinating is they say can I
have a self and you go like yeah sure no
problem I think I've given everybody a
selfie and then they go to get their
camera or get it out it's about 45
minutes 45 yeah you've got to work it
out yeah and I think it's so strange
that a complete stranger would walk up
to you and say can I have a photograph
of you and I often say no but why don't
you ask the chap over there yeah you
know what I found is sometimes they'll
be three people standing around and two
of them last me for selfie and then I'll
turn to the third one and go would you
like a picture with me and they'll say
I'm good suddenly I'm crush I don't even
know this person and I'm devastated
you